RETO MEIER: All right.
Thank you very much for joining
us, GDG Oslo, for our
second GDG App Clinic.
My name's Reto Meier.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Android team.
And joining me live from
New York is Roman
Nurik and Ian Ni-Lewis.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Roman--
did I mention that we're
in New York?
Roman's in New York,
and so am I.
RETO MEIER: Very nice.
So we're going to take a look
at a few apps from the
excellent developers in Oslo.
You've got your work
cut out for you.
The guys from Prague we looked
at last time were pretty
impressive.
So we'll have to see how well
you do for the North.
So without further ado, I'd like
to invite the developer
of NSB to come up and tell us a
little bit out their app and
about themselves.
And we can go from there.
JON: Hello?
RETO MEIER: Hello, welcome
to the show.
JON: Thank you.
Greetings from Norway.
RETO MEIER: So tell us a little
bit about your app.
And introduce yourself,
of course, please.
JON: Yeah.
My name is Jon.
I'm from NSB.
I'm a digital consultant.
And I'm going to talk
about the NSB
app, which we submitted.
It's the 5.0 version, so
it's not released yet.
The current version
is 4.04, actually.
[INAUDIBLE].
And so the new version has
a flat design and so on.
And the meaning with the app
is for the Norwegian train
company called NSB to increase
ticket availability, get
real-time travel updates,
and the ability to get a
ticket on the phone.
RETO MEIER: So this is NSB.
So this is the new front page.
And as you can see, it shares a
little of the same thematic
elements as the previous
version.
But we've kind of lost that
dashboard pattern with the
big, giant, oversized buttons
which was one of the bits of
feedback that had beforehand.
So already, this is looking
a lot nicer.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The design
here is really good.
It's really clean.
There's a lot of things
to like about it.
The main thing that bothered me
when we first loaded it up
is that so many things
are blank.
So for instance, if you press
the button labeled Train
journey, now you've used it a
little bit in the sense that
you have a couple
of favorites.
I see they begin with A, just
like my favorites do.
But before you have anything
in the favorites or the
journey, or before you've
performed any search, that
area below the search
bar is simply blank.
However, if you click in the
search bar, which you might
want to do right now, I
don't know actually
what's going to happen.
So that brings up a list
of matching stations.
And if you don't have anything
in the search
bar, they're all there.
So my first piece of advice is
that should always appear.
It's just logical.
There's no reason that it should
suddenly appear when
you click on the search bar
versus not being there to
begin with.
The favorites are more
or less the same way.
When you don't have any
favorites, it's literally just
a blank screen.
And the user has no way to
interact with it, which is
disturbing.
So my suggestion would be that
you actually have something at
the top of the screen that,
for instance, an
Add Favorites item.
I don't know how you go about
it, Roman, but I'm a big fan
of lists whose last item
is Add Another Item.
ROMAN NURIK: That's kind of
following the principle of
direct manipulation, that the
actions that you can take on
the thing you're working on are
directly on top of what
you're working on.
So it's kind of like if you
remove an item from a list, so
swipe it away.
If you add an item to the list,
it's at the bottom of
the list where that
item had appeared.
You've added it to
that [INAUDIBLE].
IAN NI-LEWIS: So if you plan
a journey, I think this is
really where it shines.
You set a--
RETO MEIER: I'm getting a
server error, which is
unfortunate.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, you
can't see it on there.
So now you search for
a couple stations.
You plan a journey from them.
And with one exception, I think
it's a wonderful UI.
Unfortunately, with Reto's
server error, the one
exception keeps popping up over
and over, which is the
"Your ticket is valid
from" spinner.
Props to making a spinner
that's flat.
One thing we've noticed, though,
is that even though
the spinner, back in 2006,
was just really trendy,
it hasn't aged well.
It's not actually as convenient
a UI as you think
it might be.
And you've noticed that we've
moved off the spinner in some
of our apps towards more direct
things like numeric
keypads that seem to
work a lot better.
ROMAN NURIK: And sometimes for
calendars, especially,
[INAUDIBLE] free, right?
So you can actually use 30-day
month calendars that you flip
up and down between the
different months.
It's a little more square, so
it works better in different
aspect ratios.
It's scrollable, so it
definitely works for longer
content with the
longer spaces.
But it's just really easy to
wrap your head around.
So you can actually visually
see the days of the week.
I think days of the week are
one of the most important
aspects of choosing a date,
especially when you're
planning a trip.
You're probably planning a
trip around a weekend, or
around a specific date
like going out or
[INAUDIBLE], whatever.
And visually seeing the place
in the week that you're
choosing something will give you
that extra bit of content.
So I definitely recommend
something
like a month calendar.
I think we've started using the
month, a 30-day view, in
some of our apps.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
When I see something like this,
my first thought is, oh,
I guess your project manager
has an iPhone.
JON: I do.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
It's unfortunate that we can't
quite get to the last bit
where we actually
see the ticket.
But I think one of the things
which I noticed in the
previous version, and I've seen
a little bit of it here
as well, is that every time
you do something which
requires contact with the
server, we get a little
flash-up dialog telling us
that we're communicate
something with the server.
That's something which I really
think takes away from
the magic of how mobile
phones work.
We all know that it's connected
to the internet, and
it needs to talk to
your server and
do all of that stuff.
You kind of want your users to
think that it's just a magic
thing where your phone
just knows how
to pull train things.
And the fact that there's an
internet connection and mobile
telephony all about
is just kind of
completely hidden away.
So you want to try and make
sure that you're not
displaying any of those sorts
of dialogs, particularly
because usually, they just
come up really quickly.
You have sort of a flash
of talking to server.
And if it all works,
it flashes away.
And you just kind of think
as a user, what was that?
Was that important?
Should I have read that?
So you really want to try and
just disguise all of that,
unless something goes wrong.
And if it does go wrong, try and
be as descriptive as you
can in a way that doesn't rely
on understanding how your app
is being implemented
to your user.
So something like, unable
to buy train tickets.
No connection to
internet found.
Something like that is more
useful than, server
communication error, where the
user is like, I don't know
what any of that means.
Did I do something wrong?
Rather than, OK, well, I can
try again later because my
connectivity is down, which they
may be more easily able
to understand.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So we just got the
schedule, which you may be
able to see here if I can
hold it still enough.
I realize that's coming
through very well.
You can see that's a really
clean design.
It's got the nice red
band at the top.
Everything else is monochrome,
but there's a fairly good
differentiation using fonts
and highlighting.
I think based on the specific
application, and I'm not
familiar with the trains of
Norway at all, but I can
readily believe that they are
all color-coded in different
shades of gray.
But if they're not, and if
there is any kind of
color-coding, that might be a
really nice additional effect
is to add some more information
that's going to
help people find the platform
for the particular train that
they're looking for.
But this does a pretty
good job of not
being too busy, I think.
I don't know.
If I were to redesign this, I
might just use a thin font on
the city names.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, that's one
of the best ways to add a
touch of elegance to your apps
as well as help even further
the visual hierarchy that
you get from text.
Use different weights of Roboto,
different sizes--
not too many different sizes, at
most maybe two or really at
most three different sizes.
But different font weights would
really help [INAUDIBLE]
the hierarchy.
But yeah, like you said,
the hierarchy is
very evident as is.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think Roman
would probably say that
putting the entire time in
the same weight is wrong.
Of course, the hours should
be bold, and the minutes--
just kidding.
Yeah, this looks really good.
And especially, I don't know if
you can see it, but I love
the way that the platform
is in a little box.
They make it really easy to see
it and also is a little
kind of elegant.
So that's very nice.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I
have to say, the
biggest feedback I have--
I have a page of notes which
I've tried to take
on each of the apps.
And they were all based
on version 4.
And version 5 fixes
all of them.
So my feedback is nice
job on version 5.
You've really updated the app,
brought it into the modern age
of Android where it's action
bar, Holo theme, a nice,
clean, flat line.
There's a lack of clutter.
Simple, intuitive navigation.
So all of the little niggles
that I had around making it
sort of more of a modern,
up-to-date app, I think you've
absolutely nailed.
So nicely done.
ROMAN NURIK: The one thing I
wanted to mention is about the
home screen.
We spent a little bit
of time talking
about onboarding flows.
And I think that outside of the
Google playlist thing, the
very first thing you see in the
app is probably your most
important screen.
It's almost a hero moment.
So I would spend even more time
on this landing screen to
tweak it a bit.
Right now, it feels
very static.
That's one of the problems, one
of the reasons we've moved
away from the dashboard pattern
and anything that
basically just has
links on it.
We've moved more towards a
content-driven home screen.
So one of the things that you
may want to consider doing is
things like profile.
You want to move it to the
action bar, since it is
navigation, but it's often
treated as an action.
It's kind of like a common thing
is to put the profile in
the overflow or something.
And then things like "View
ticket," if you don't have a
ticket, is there any reason to
show that, I'm guessing?
But you could also just
have it as a--
I don't want to say card, but
have it as a scrollable item
you can get to.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Another thing to
think about is, this would be
a perfect opportunity
to use some of
the new action detection.
Because if you know that the
person is in the middle of a
train journey, then probably the
first thing they want to
do is view a ticket.
That's probably why they pulled
it out of their pocket
to begin with because
the conductor is
coming down the aisle.
That would be a truly magical
moment to always see exactly
what you need and then perhaps
hide some of this other stuff
either on the action bar or in
a drawer or some other way,
some other well understood
way to access these
navigational tools.
ROMAN NURIK: So it's almost
like Google Now tries to
predict what you may be
most interested in.
Here, you may be able to say, if
you think that the user is
in a place where they
want to access that
ticket, show that ticket.
Actually show the actual ticket
at the very top, and
then show other options like
favorites and then let's say
like even potentially place the
entire search screen or
the beginning of the search
process into this screen.
So you basically give easy
access, immediate access to
the very first step of
each of those flows.
And then once the user decides
that, hey, yeah, I do want to
vies the full ticket, they just
touch that tile, and they
get taken to the full
ticket view.
But then the position
is based on things
like activity detection.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Another thing
that I think would be
incredibly useful here but
significantly more work would
be integration with
a Map view.
That's one of the things
I notice when I--
I frequently need transit in a
city that I'm unfamiliar with.
And the first thing I'll do is
open my map and figure out
where I need to go, try to find
a station nearby and then
get directions to that.
So that's one thing that could
be really nice if you fell
that many of your users
might be going
to unfamiliar locations.
Of course, if they're going to
familiar locations, it's great
to just have those favorites
in hand.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
In fact, that's probably one
of the bits of feedback I
have, based on what Ian and
Roman have just been talking
about, is that right now, your
home screen kind of looks as
though it was designed based
on your API endpoints.
So we have an API which lets us
call for the train journey.
We have another one which lets
us retrieve our favorites, one
which gives us access
to our profile.
But it's sort of data-driven
design.
It would be really interesting
to see a reimagined version of
the home screen based around the
guidelines that Roman and
Ian were talking about, which
is, what does a user want to
do when they open up the app?
What are they thinking?
What are the most likely things
for someone who uses
this every day, for someone
who is visiting Oslo?
How are they going to take
advantage of the app?
And try and think about
redesigning the UI from the
perspective of what you want
to do rather than what's
available for you to do.
So I definitely agree.
I think putting things like the
ticket on the bottom of
the main screen seems like
an obvious thing to me.
If I have a ticket already, and
it's valid, have it there.
And if I don't, it seems like
the most likely thing I want
to do with the app
is buy a ticket.
So having a big plus symbol
there so that you can initiate
that action right from
the beginning seems
like it might be useful.
So yeah, I would consider
redesigning the home screen,
which is really the only thing
which hasn't changed much in
the redesigns, to be more of a,
what is it that you think
people want to do, and reduce
the number of steps for them
to be able to get to the
specific action that they have
installed this app for.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now before we
move on, though, I want to
point out the one feature that
none of us talked about, but
which is really incredibly
well done, and that's
localization.
RETO MEIER: Yes.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We did not ask
for this app in English.
But here it is, showing us
almost completely in English,
except for I don't know
what Ruter is.
RETO MEIER: It's the name
of the company.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh.
Well, there you go.
RETO MEIER: I wondered
the same.
It's the equivalent of
Amtrak, I guess.
But yeah.
No, I absolutely,
totally agree.
This is something which a lot
of people overlook when
they're building apps for a
specific application is they
figure, well, you don't
need to localize the
train app for Norway.
It's going to be used by
Norwegian people--
except when it isn't, which is
what I found out when I was
traveling around Italy trying to
buy tickets on Trenitalia.
And their website does
not localize to
anything but Italian.
And that makes it an intriguing
challenge to buy
Eurail tickets in a
foreign country.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Everybody
can read Italian.
Come on.
RETO MEIER: Well,
I prefer not to.
But yeah, this sort of thinking
as to who all your
potential users are is really,
really valuable because
suddenly, you have everyone
who's visiting is going to use
this app because it's
all localized.
They feel comfortable.
It looks familiar.
It works in a familiar
way, and they
understand what it says.
So yeah, thank you
for localizing.
It certainly makes our jobs
as reviewers easier.
And I think it's going to help
to grow your audience of
potential users online
as well.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Which languages
are you localized into?
JON: Sorry?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Which languages
do you have translations for
in your app?
JON: I think it's connected
through the
language in the phone.
But I think it's only in
Norwegian in English.
IAN NI-LEWIS: OK.
You might want to add Chinese.
JON: Chinese?
OK, noted.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, it's
an easy one.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All the Chinese
[INAUDIBLE] sees this.
RETO MEIER: That's true, yeah.
All right, perfect.
Thank you, Jon, and thank you
for your patience in letting
us detour around your app
and come back into it.
Do you have anything else that
you'd like to add in terms of
responding to our feedback or
things which you have a plan
to do but perhaps haven't had
time to implement in the
current version?
JON: Not really.
I'm going to take the notes back
to the team, and we'll
discuss it.
RETO MEIER: Awesome.
We're looking forward to seeing
version 5 when it comes
out for real.
It's definitely a great job and
a really good update, so
nicely done.
JON: Yeah, thank you Thank
you very much.
ALEX: Hi.
I'm Alex.
I'm the creator of
Phonelocator.
RETO MEIER: Hey, Alex.
ALEX: This project started in
2007 on Symbian when Android
was just in its infancy.
So the idea back then was to
track my motorcycle tour
around Europe.
I wanted to show my friends back
home where I was, where
my friend was at well.
So I made the app.
It had no login, no nothing.
It just showed--
there was just a website, and
you could just see where this
one Nokia phone was.
In those days, GPS on phones
was completely new.
So quite late, actually, last
year, I released this Android
version, which represents
about 120 hours of work.
It has all the same features
in it that
the Symbian one did.
Which it kind to morphed into a
security product long before
it was built into your iPhone
or Android device.
So you can send this phone a
text message containing the
word alarm.
I think my friend's going
to try that now.
And it will sound an alarm so
you can find the phone.
[ALARM]
ALEX: So it creates
a notification.
You have to deactivate
the notification.
You can choose whether or not
you want to hide that message
so that the person who has the
phone can see it or not.
You can set a passcode as well
so that the person who has the
phone has to type in a passcode
before they can
disable the alarm.
It has a bugging message
feature.
So if the SIM card on the phone
is changed, it will text
a pre-defined number saying,
this is the new number that's
in the telephone.
And of course, it periodically
updates its location So you
can see the time that
it's going to
update in, in 10 minutes.
You have to be pretty
conservative with the updates.
It was before this
new Google Play
services, low power stuff.
I had to code it all myself to
try and decide whether it's
going to use GPS or Wi-Fi to
work out where the phone is.
Yeah, so the Symbian version had
400,000 registered users.
The Android version is
a fraction of that.
Only a few thousands people
have used it, I think.
So yeah, that's Phonelocator.
RETO MEIER: OK, nice, so thank
you for the update.
So I had a few thoughts
based on my first
experience of using it.
And I think probably the biggest
feedback I have is
that it's not immediately
obvious when you install it
what it does or how to use it.
So without getting your
two-minute intro there, it's
not entirely clear.
You have to create a login, and
then it takes your GPS and
sends it to a server.
But it's not immediately obvious
when I'm using the app
what it's doing with
any of that data.
ALEX: What it does.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, exactly.
So it sort of starts to get
you a little bit nervous.
And also, the amount of time
it takes to get set up is
longer than you'd expect.
You have to go to the website
to create this whole profile
and user name and--
ALEX: I knew you
would say that.
So let me tell you why.
It's not really an excuse.
But there's some legacy there.
This app was made before it was
actually standard to use
ACDP and JSON to actually
update.
So it uses a really
low-bandwidth protocol to send
the updates to the server,
binary protocol.
And in those days, making
forms of things on
Symbian was hard work.
So I thought, well, why not
just do it on the web?
And then when I came to do the
Android version, I nearly
changed it so it had a proper
login screen and everything.
But in the end, I thought, oh,
I'll just use the same web
interface rather than
recoding it.
But I take the point.
It's not very intuitive.
RETO MEIER: Well, see now,
you've got an advantage.
You could actually take
advantage of the fact that
you've procrastinated this
long and just use Google+
Sign-In instead.
So then you don't have
to do the form or
anything like that.
It gets simple.
So you get rewarded for
having put it off.
But that might be a neat way to
reduce the friction of that
initial sign-in for it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I would like to
say one thing about that.
So there's two things that are
really important about the
beginning of your app.
First is that you can
do something without
having to log in.
That's something that is
difficult to do, but in this
case, for instance, there are
some features that you could
enable without logging in that
might give the user some idea
of what they're getting into.
But the other thing is--
ALEX: So how could that look?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, for
instance, in this case, you
can set your buddy message.
I think there's a couple other
things, some settings and
things like that.
Obviously, the app has
no functionality.
But for instance, the screen
we're looking at now could
give some message like, would
have a next update in two
minutes if you were logged
in, which you're not.
And then have a facility
for logging you in.
The other thing that you want to
think about, though, is how
many clicks it takes
to log in.
On the website form,
it's a lot.
And--
ALEX: I f agree with the
previous comment.
It's got to change.
This app is actually going to be
retired and replaced with a
new brand that's something
completely awesome.
ROMAN NURIK: Actually, a similar
thing you could do,
and this is all part of that
onboarding flow which is so
important, especially if
you ever get featured.
A lot of people get into your
app that don't know about your
brand, don't know
what it does.
One of the things you could
do is say, here's
your current location.
Like let's say we're
in New York.
And then maybe even show a
preview of the website.
This is kind of crazy, but if
you show a preview of the
website showing the map with
your location, saying, here's
what you would see if you
were on a computer
and you had the service.
You would see that your
phone is in New York.
So you could almost use the live
data and see where the
person is, because you
don't need a login
to get their location.
And then just kind of show a
fake version of the website
showing that location.
That might be some way of
communicating the value in a
direct way, rather than
just talking about it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Remember that
we've done a lot of work to
make it easy to download and
install lots of apps.
So one usage pattern we see a
lot is that people will search
for a term, install 5 or 10
apps that seem to have
associations with that term, and
then they will uninstall
the ones that they don't like
after about 20 seconds of use.
So the first 20 or 30 seconds
are absolutely crucial.
In fact, I'd even say the first
five seconds is crucial.
ALEX: OK, so it's just
like a web page.
You've got a few seconds to
impress, and then that's it.
You've blown it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
ROMAN NURIK: On that point,
it's not even after you
install the app.
It's before you even
So the screen shots, the app
icon on Google Play, the
description, all of that is part
of that user experience,
that initial onboarding
experience.
The very first time the user has
any sort of communication
with your brand or any sort
of interaction with you is
through that.
So that is even before
you get to the app.
ALEX: That's a very kind
way of putting it.
Thank you.
I've got a new brand.
It's made by a designer,
not by me.
I'm a developer.
And it looks really cool.
RETO MEIER: Awesome.
Thanks.
ALEX: By the way, this
app is open source.
So anybody who's watching and
wants to get involved, then
that would be brilliant,
if they can find me.
It's on GitHub.
RETO MEIER: Excellent.
So a couple of other points
along the same lines.
I think probably the biggest
feedback is based on where the
app has come from.
So it's an app that has been
around for a long time based
originally on Symbian.
I think we all know that
the world has changed
significantly in terms of the
way mobile phone apps look and
work since that time.
Even though a surprisingly
short period of time has
passed, a lot has changed.
So I think a lot of the feedback
is going to be along
those lines.
I'd love to see you integrate
the new location-based
services as well to try and help
make the location updates
a little bit more efficient.
And Google+ Sign-In as well,
as an alternative to
potentially having to create
a new account each time.
I also noticed that we are
forced into portrait mode that
doesn't work on a tablet.
Which makes a lot of sense
in some instances.
But it might be interesting to
see how an app like this would
work on a tablet, if there is
some functionality that you
could continue to use, things
like the GPS updates would,
even if the security aspects
of being able to call the
phone aren't available.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You might also
want to give just a little bit
more thought to your
action bar layout.
It doesn't seem like the
ordering of the menu is
effective in terms of getting
the most important things on
the action bar.
There are some things that
probably shouldn't ever leave
the overflow menu.
For instance, settings is almost
never necessary as an
action bar button.
I also noticed that if you do
go to, for instance, buddy
message settings.
Can you do that, Reto,
on your phone?
No, not settings, but
buddy message
settings, which is also--
that's something that might want
to live under settings
rather than under a different
menu item.
This page, I think, would be
really a good candidate for
the Done Cancel action
bar pattern.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
ALEX: OK.
RETO MEIER: And one of the good
things about this app is
that it's simple.
It doesn't have a
cluttered UI.
You don't have a million
different things confronting
you on screen.
But you've almost gone too far
in that direction, in that a
lot of this stuff, you could
quite easily have put on the
main screen, because all we
have there is a countdown.
So you could certainly add a few
more elements to that to
explain what happens when
that countdown runs out.
And basically, like this buddy
message, for example, you
could have that displayed
on screen.
ALEX: If you don't set the buddy
message, it does warn
you that you've not set
the buddy message--
RETO MEIER: It does.
ALEX: --on the main screen.
RETO MEIER: But it doesn't
tell me what that means.
It just says, you haven't
set a buddy message.
And it's like, OK, is
that a bad thing?
IAN NI-LEWIS: I don't even know
what a buddy message is.
RETO MEIER: Precisely.
I'm still not sure what
a buddy message is.
yeah, so this is what
we get, the, you
haven't set a buddy message.
And you have the button to fix
it, which is good that it's an
actionable prompt to be able
to go in there and fix.
But again, you have no idea of
what the implications are.
And as a user, the first time
I open up the app, this is
what I see.
And so I'm basically being
told, hey, you're doing
something wrong.
You haven't done
this thing yet.
So I don't even know if you
deserve to use my app.
Which isn't really the kind of
feeling you want to give
people, right?
You want to make them feel
happy, feel like they're doing
the right thing, and that if
there's something which isn't
set, it's, I'm sure you just
haven't gotten around to it,
or here's a thing which we could
use to make this app
even more useful to you.
So you want to provide a
little bit of context.
You want to try and be more
positive in terms of the
messaging and in terms of what
this will allow you to do,
rather than how you haven't
done this thing.
ALEX: OK.
Cool.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, so I think
that's about all the feedback
that I had.
I don't know if there's any
more specific stuff.
The thing is, it's not
particularly complex, which
means that once you get kind of
past those initial bits of
feedback, there's not too much
else that we can provide at
this stage.
But hopefully that's
useful for you.
Is there anything else--
ALEX: Yeah, thanks
very much, guys.
Really appreciate that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Cool,
yeah, thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Hello.
Can you hear me?
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: Fantastic.
OK, first off, just thank you
very much for doing this.
We really appreciate you
taking the time.
And so the Finn app,
where to start?
I can tell you a little
bit about the company.
It's a reasonably recognized
company in Norway in terms of
a lot of people know
who Finn are.
And the websites have about 3
and 1/2 million visitors a
week, unique visitors.
And there are like 5 million
people in Norway.
And it's a marketplace
for properties,
bits and pieces, cars.
It's a place where you go
to find jobs, et cetera.
So what we've done is we're
actually in the process of
making this Android app.
It's in alpha at the moment, and
there's a few months away
from launch.
It's the first time we're
actually showing it off to
anyone outside Finn, so
that's pretty cool.
RETO MEIER: Wow, thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: And the idea
behind the app is to make it
faster for people to access
the content, of Finn.
So at the moment, we have a web
platform for mobile phones.
And what happens is if you go
onto Finn, you have to go
through a number of steps
in order to do a search.
So what a lot of people do is
they go onto Finn and then
dream about upgrading the house
or whatever, so they
spend a lot of time searching
through the
things that are on Finn.
And in our current web app for
mobile, what you have to do is
you open it up, and then you
click on a market, and then
you click on a sub-market, and
then you have to select a
location and go through all
the filters, and then you
click search, and then you're
at the results page.
So it's like a very
long process.
So what we wanted to do with
this app was try to squeeze
down the navigation path a
little bit and also do
something that we haven't
done before.
And that is to try to be a
little bit smart about how we
deliver updates and relevant
info to the user.
So we have the main page, the
landing page that you see when
you open up, it's like
a stream of content.
And the idea is for that content
to show new hits on
the searches that you have going
on and updates to things
that you're looking for.
RETO MEIER: All right.
So why don't you tell us a
little bit about what we're
missing while I get it
installed over here?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, it's
a very pretty app.
Now the navigation departs
pretty significantly from what
we consider to be current
Android standards.
We certainly can't say
that it's bad.
It's just non-standard, so
it has the possibility of
confusing the user and maybe
making their learning curve a
little higher than
it has to be.
It doesn't use the standard
action bar, for instance.
It uses a non-standard drawer
patterns that actually
confused me already because
there seem to be multiple
drawers that come out
at different times.
But it is a very
beautiful app.
It's sort of card-based,
a little bit--
it's very, very open and easy
on the eyes, lots of open
space, maybe a little
too much.
But not much, like the margins
[INAUDIBLE] cards [INAUDIBLE].
You'll see what we're talking
about in just a second here.
I'll go ahead and wait
for you [INAUDIBLE].
RETO MEIER: Great.
We can switch.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I do want to know
what the exchange rate is
because I'm seeing some amazing
houses I'm thinking
about buying.
ALEX: Yeah, you don't want to.
It's very pricey in Norway.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, well, we live
in the Silicon Valley,
and I can assure you it's
not cheap here.
So we have the right
person on screen
right now, which proves--
it's a good example, right?
So what we saw beforehand was
what happens if you just get a
website, wrap it in a native
wrapper, and stick it up.
It doesn't look great.
It's slow.
It's janky.
It's really not an optimized
situation.
So what we have here is exactly
what happens when you
do it the right way and create
something which is truly
native to give that
richer experience.
So we can see what you were
talking about now with that
stream of content.
Right on the landing page, as
soon as you go in, you're
shown things.
So suddenly, you're not having
to think about navigating
through different areas of
shopping, but you're shown
actual content that you can
engage in gets you thinking
about what it is that you're
interested in.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So if I can ask a
question, I'm going through
these cards.
They all have the same heading,
which is Finn.no.
I don't see any difference.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so just to
explain that very quickly, the
idea is for that stream that
you see on the home page to
have content that relates to
your searches, so new results
on searches that you make.
But we haven't been able to
implement that bit yet.
We're sort of in the process
of doing it.
But we have what we call curated
content as well, which
we call the Finn cat.
We have a mascot.
It's really weird, but we have
a mascot that is a cat, and
he's really sarcastic, and he
makes all these sarcastic
comments about different
things.
So that's the cat that's sort
of posting all these little
updates onto the stream.
So the idea is to have a mix of
updates from that cat but
also like new hits on the
searches that you're making.
RETO MEIER: I would love
to get updates
from a sarcastic cat.
That sounds like the coolest
feature so far.
ROMAN NURIK: That's such a
great way to form a true
emotional bond with your user is
to give them a personality
that they're working with,
almost like when they open the
app, they're kind of
talking to the cat.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I particularly
like the idea
that it's a sarcastic
cat, too.
It's not like a helpful,
friendly cat.
ALEX: Makes all the
difference.
RETO MEIER: It's totally in your
face, making fun of you.
And I think that's excellent.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I hope not.
So I think the one thing that
I'm seeing on the home screen
is I'm very comfortable with the
design, but it does seem
like it's going to take me
a while to get anywhere.
And I wonder if there's
something, a few techniques
that you could use to, for
instance, compress some of the
information.
You know, once I've seen the
photos, I may-- and this is
why I asked about
the headers--
I may be able to locate the
card that I'm looking for
afterwards just by looking
at the headers.
So you could do something like
slide cards over the top of
one another or shrink them down
or something once the
user has seen them so that
getting to the bottom or
navigating around doesn't
take as many swipes.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, you could use
a similar approach to what
we have in Google now, where
some of the cards sort of
consist of other cards layered
on top of each other that you
press to expand or move
around that way.
It could be quite interesting.
Yeah, it's a very
attractive-looking app.
It's interesting the way you've
implemented a sliding
drawer for search.
So this is basically where you
have your categories, as well
as the actual searching,
is that right?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
that's right.
So that's all the
main markets.
And there are more markets
to be added onto that.
RETO MEIER: OK.
And I assume that what I'm
reading on screen here means
search Finn.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
so that's a global
search for all the markets.
RETO MEIER: Cool.
What do you think about the idea
of using a drawer pattern
for search categories, Roman?
ROMAN NURIK: Overall, my
feedback here is that the
drawer, like you mentioned in
the beginning, the drawer
being used in different ways
as well as hierarchy within
the drawer, actually having a
back button or I guess up
within the drawer is going to
lead folks to be somewhat
confused because you end up
creating lots of modes and
states where I could
actually see the--
I could get the drawer to its
child screen, like what you
have now, slide over
the content.
And then maybe a few minutes
later, I slide over to expand,
and I completely forgot the
drawer was in the mode of a
child view.
So there's a lot of hierarchy
in the drawer.
There's a lot of different
states for the drawer.
I'd really try to
simplify that.
The other thing is that we
obviously do have guidelines.
I don't want to talk too much
about guidelines here.
But we do have navigation
drawer guidelines.
These do depart quite
a bit from there.
So if possible, I would
try to follow those.
And really, once you start
searching, once you start
going into the flow of doing a
search, you may want to just
replace the main content
with the search filter.
That might simplify things.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I think
you're absolutely right.
I think that's where it gets
confusing is that once you're
on this screen here, then
search actually
means refine search.
Which is fine, except that it's
different from what you
have in the home screen, where
search means allow me to
search or let me sort
by category.
So it's kind of different
content, even if it's related.
I also always find it a little
bit disconcerting when you
have two sliding panels.
So we have the sliding drawer
on the left search, and we
have the sliding drawer on
the right for logging in.
That, particularly this login
piece, feels like it should be
part of an action bar or
something like that.
I think this is very
non-discoverable.
And I assume that pressing
that is the same thing.
So you press the profile
button, and
that drags it across.
But I think the idea of the way
that we use the sliding
panels and the drawers, as
Roman says, this is very
different from the way we have
them in the design guidelines.
And so it can be a little
bit disconcerting or
counter-intuitive to users who
are expecting it to in a
certain way.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
It's sad, though, because it's
absolutely beautiful.
The action here and the
animation, the colors, it's
just really, really nice.
And I'd love to see some of
those elements kept, but you
have to think about what
are your users going be
experienced with.
It's always tempting to go with
an entirely new design.
It's also very tempting
sometimes to import a design
from another mobile
device family.
But you have to remember,
someone who's had their
Android phone for a while, who
loves it, will have interacted
with a lot of apps that offer
similar navigation and
functionality to yours, perhaps
in a different vertical.
And this will be a learning
experience, and learning
experiences are sometimes fun,
but they're often frustrating
when you have a task in mind
that you want to get done.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
I just wanted to mention that
we're actually struggling a
little bit to find a
suitable pattern.
So we did look through quite a
few Android apps and Android
guidelines looking for something
that sort of
combined drilling into your
markets and also having the
filters there.
Another reason we did it like
this was because it scaled up
quite nicely when you're
on a tablet.
So you can have the filter
constantly available on the
left hand side, so you can tweak
the filters while seeing
real-time updates of
the results on
the right hand side.
So it works.
We thought this was something
that kind of-- we know that
it's not optimal.
But we didn't find a better
solution, to be honest.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I hear
what you're saying.
I think for the tablet layout,
it would look great.
I think it's exactly the sort of
layout that you want to use
where you have everything
on screen.
Here, it almost feels
as though--
I think it's, as well, rather
than any individual problem,
it's more of a combination of
a lot of paradigms that are
being used slightly differently
from how you
would expect it.
And so then as an experienced
Android user, you start to get
confused as to what you need
to do to navigate around.
It's primarily around
navigation.
So here, for example, I'm
expecting to be able to swat
to bring something back,
but I can't.
Here, it's back, which is an up
button which looks similar
to what I would expect
an up button to be,
but it looks different.
So it, again, gives me that
pause for thought, like, what
is this going to do?
So you're never quite sure how
to navigate back to where
you're from.
Because here I need to either
hit back, or I need to bring
my navigation drawer back and
then hit back in order to
return to the previous menu.
That's kind of unexpected.
I never expect to have to slide
out a drawer before I'm
able to navigate back
up in the hierarchy.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now I'm going to
take a slightly contradictory
position to Reto and say, this
app feels very designed.
And it feels like every
interview, that I have, every
question I have about
navigation, is solved in an
elegant matter.
I do agree that it's completely
non-standard, but I
think we should recognize
that a lot of thought
has gone into this.
And there's some interesting
problems.
What I would really love to see,
if Roman's up for it, is
to have this be an "Android
Design in Action" candidate
and talk a little bit about the
challenges that you faced,
how you solved them, and see if
we can find something that
fits into the Android
standard that
solves the mess elegantly.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROMAN NURIK: There's a lot
of hierarchy here.
That's one of the hardest things
you can deal with as a
designer is dealing with
different hierarchies and
different flows as well as,
obviously, what you mentioned
before, the tablet versus
[INAUDIBLE].
How do things work, how
do things respond
to different sizes?
Definitely, in the next few
episodes of "Android Design in
Action," we were looking to get
back into the redesign or
the re-imagining world.
So definitely, this is one of
the apps I would consider.
RETO MEIER: I think it's
one of the challenges.
I've seen this a lot from apps
which are trying to do some
sort of shopping, or anything
where you have to navigate
through multiple categories
and do multiple sort of
filtering on each of
those categories
becomes a real challenge.
I've seen people try and do it
using drop-downs in the action
bar or having the filter
controls here on the top of
the screen.
But then that obscures
all of the content.
So yeah, I've seen a
lot of apps try.
And having that sort of
multi-level hierarchy is
definitely a challenge.
So I would be very interested to
see what Rowan and his team
can come up with as possible
alternatives.
ROMAN NURIK: One minor t I
wanted to call out here.
So this kind of starts feeling
a little bit like this is
solving the problem of
master/detail, you have master
gets-- when you actually go
into search, you have the
search filter.
It takes a little bit of mental
gymnastics to see it,
but maybe it's like a master
on the left and
detail on the right.
And what you end up having is
basically you're now in the
cars or the guitars or things.
RETO MEIER: Motorcycles, baby.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And pressing up should actually
take you back to the
top with the stream and the
navigation on the left.
So basically, you have
two activities.
At the top, you have the
screen as well as the
navigation drawer.
But as soon as you jump into
cars or something else, you
get taken to a new activity with
a sliding pane layout,
which works on tablet as well as
phone, where the left side
is your master and the right
side is your detail.
So that's one way we
could approach it.
But definitely for "Android
Design in Action," if we get a
chance to take a look at this,
we'll see if that pans out.
It's just kind of an
off-the-cuff idea.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I have to
admit, that's the one thing.
I feel like every single page
here is beautiful, but the
navigation is a little weird.
And right now, I'm just trying
to figure out how to get back
to the sarcastic cat.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, it's
definitely a beautiful app.
I think we really want to
emphasize the fact that it
looks great.
Even understanding nothing in
terms of Norwegian, you're
still able to navigate it and
understand what's going on.
You've used icons in the right
places to be able to
understand.
Like again, here, even without
understanding what these
categories are, it's obvious to
me that they are categories
and that I can use them to
navigate into the app.
And I can figure out
where search is.
I understand how to
change prices.
I understand what I'm looking
at, what it represents.
And it actually represents a
really good example of what we
should all be doing when we
create our apps, which is
trying to use it without
being able to
understand any of the language.
Even do a localization in just
gibberish, so that the text
lengths are about the right
size, but you have no idea
what it says.
And then give it to someone
and see how well
they navigate it.
It gives you a really good idea
of how your visual cues
are working, how the layout,
how the navigation, how
everything is implying to them
what they're looking at
without actually using
the text as a cue.
And for a mobile app, this is
really important because
people don't necessarily read
what they're looking at.
It's just kind of truism
for a lot of things,
people don't read.
You can tell them things a
million times, put it on big
screens, explain something
in detail.
They're not going to read it.
They're going to skip
straight through it.
So you need to make sure that
the rest of the app pushes
them in the right direction,
gives them all of the other
cues, so that even if they're
not paying attention, they're
just glancing at the screen, or
they're making assumptions,
it works out.
It does still do what they
expect it to do and makes them
feel comfortable that they
understand how it works and
how they can interact with it.
And I think you've done a
really good job there.
It's just as we've said
repeatedly, it's just the
navigation which could use a
little bit of a tweak, and I
think otherwise, it's
a great effort.
It's a great-looking app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The one thing that
I really appreciate and I
want to point out specifically
because it's very hard to do
is that the app is buttery
smooth even though it has to
fetch quite a lot of data,
including photos.
And you can see that the photos
not only load in the
background, but they also fade
in with a nice effect, which
makes the app feel considerably
smoother and less abrupt.
So I think the engineering
behind the central list view
is really stellar, and I want
to congratulate that.
ROMAN NURIK: All right, of my
last points of constructive
criticism or feedback.
First, there's a distinct lack
of touch feedback throughout.
So when you put your finger
down on something, it
should light up.
The entire touch area should
light up to indicate that
you've begun interacting
with it.
The second thing was with those
photos, they load in
just beautifully.
But as you're scrolling through
the list, there's just
white space there.
And it almost feels like
they're just missing or
misaligned.
So you may want to use a
placeholder image, maybe even
just a slightly gray, like an
off-white color, to indicate
that this is a placeholder
state where
something will load in.
That'll potentially improve
the feeling of alignment.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
And I think that if you look
into these products, they've
actually done that in some cases
where the-- let me get
one that I haven't looked
at already-- when
the photo is loading.
No, not really.
Yeah, it's got a loading
spinner, but it's [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, I like the idea of a very
slightly darker gray box.
RETO MEIER: Just something so
that you know that something
is going to come is a
really good idea.
Everything, I love how buttery
smooth everything is.
I like that you can tell a lot
of thought has gone into how
much pre-caching you do.
So when I do load up a page for
a new article, I can swipe
once on two or three photos, and
they're there instantly.
But once I start to go much
further, then it's going to do
the reload.
So it doesn't aggressively
download all nine photos, but
it will get the first four, the
ones which I'm most likely
to look at.
Those little touches can make
a really big difference, so
nicely done.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The other
thing I'm really a
fan of here, Reto--
I want you to check it out.
I don't know how you feel.
But I feel like swiping through
photos, obviously, I
want to either look at
one or the other.
And I've worked with some apps
where you really do need to
swipe it all the way across, and
it's a big finger gesture.
You'll notice, this, after
you've moved about maybe 5 or
10 millimeters, it'll simply
swipe over to the next one.
So it just takes a very tiny
gesture to get it to move from
one photo to the other.
I really appreciate that because
it saves my thumbs,
and my thumbs are arthritic.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I'm
not quite seeing
it happen that quickly.
It needs to go about halfway as
far as my eyes can see it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Huh.
Yeah, it's definitely
velocity-sensitive.
And I think that's probably
appropriate.
So if you try--
RETO MEIER: Yeah, it's a very
small throw will transfer.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Once you get above a
certain velocity
threshold, and that's great.
That just feels really good.
I think that's an excellent
gesture.
RETO MEIER: There are only two
other things which Roman has
prompted me on which
are worth noting.
So one is that where you have
the action bar icons up here,
they don't have tooltips
associated.
So you want to make
sure that they do.
So if people long-press on
these, it'll tell them what it
is that they're trying
to accomplish,
which is always useful.
Particularly for people with
visual impairments, those
sorts of things make a really
big difference.
And while we're talking touch
targets, it would be, I think,
really useful to allow users to
select some of the text in
the description fields for the
items that they're looking at.
So you do have a mechanism for
sharing, which will allow you
to send a link to that
particular item to someone.
Great, really useful.
But I think it would also be
useful to be able to quickly
and easily select things like
the price or the description
so that they can take that, cut
it, paste it, put it into
something else, maybe an email,
maybe a document,
Google Keep, whatever it is that
they're doing to try and
keep track of things.
So I think adding that
flexibility would be really,
really useful.
IAN NI-LEWIS: By the way, going
back to what we were
talking about in some of the
other apps about what can you
do when you're not logged
in, check out--
press the little heart button,
which in my opinion, should
probably be a star, but
heart, whatever.
Now there's no explanatory text
here, and there probably
should be, but this is a good
example of how you can provide
value without being logged in.
You get to a point in the app
where you have to be logged
in, in this case, to set a
favorite, and you're given the
opportunity to log in there.
At least, I think that's
what's going on.
RETO MEIER: I believe so.
I think the one comment I have
here is that there doesn't
appear to be a way to create
an account if you don't
already have one.
Is that because you can't?
MALE SPEAKER: No,
no, it's coming.
We just haven't gotten
around to it yet.
RETO MEIER: It isn't completely
finished?
I'm outraged.
So the other thing, and I know
that given this is a retail
store, and I know how this
works, and I'm sure that you
have your own database of
people's profiles, which
you're creating on purpose.
If it doesn't have this
complicated back end, it would
be interesting, again, to think
of using something like
Google+ to simplify that login
process so that I don't need
to go through and create
an account.
I hate creating accounts
on my phone.
I very seldom do.
It's usually a good reason for
me to decide not to use an
app, if I have to go
through this whole
process of doing something.
Whereas with Google+, it's
much, much easier.
It's just a one click login
and then accept.
So something to consider if you
don't have restrictions
preventing you from being able
to take that approach.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And this isn't
just a plug for Google+.
There are other apps.
For instance, in America, it's
very common to have a Twitter
or Facebook account
on the phone.
Any account provider that's
installed an account provider
plug-in on the phone
will offer your
users a one-touch login.
So if you want to log in with
Twitter, you want to log in
with Google+, you want
to offer multiple
options, that's fine.
The most important thing is that
they can log in with just
a couple of touches because
that will keep them coming
back to your app.
That will prevent them from
uninstalling your app out of
frustration because they
don't have an account.
So you'll see a greater
attach rating.
RETO MEIER: It's also a really
great way of maintaining users
across devices.
So if they get a new phone, or
if they buy a new tablet and
are able to log in and get all
of the customizations that
they did for free without having
to remember the user
name and password that they
created two years ago, it
really helps just to encourage
people to, as Ian said, log
back in and keep
using your app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: A lot of people
that run very popular services
don't think this is very
important because they know
that many of their users have
installed this app because
they love the service.
But if you look at the way the
trends are going, that's not
going to last much longer.
There's been a period of several
years where mobile
uptake was driven by users who
had used the website and
enjoyed it and wanted the same
thing on their device.
But if you look at our
statistics for usage, we're
seeing many more people
interacting with the web and
services on their mobile phone
to the point where it's very
likely that the majority of your
new users will come from
the mobile experience
in the future.
So being able to offer them
the quickest possible to
usable behavior and useful
functionality is going to be
really important to
your bottom line.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
And it's all about retention
as well.
I went through the process
last weekend, while I was
shopping, of trying to install
and register my Safeway app.
While my wife was shopping, I
was pushing the trolley trying
to get the Safeway
app installed.
And I had to create an account
and then associate it with my
Safeway card, and the whole
thing took like half an hour.
Which was fine, because it beats
shopping, but wasn't the
best experience in terms of
encouraging me to actually use
the app, let alone recommend
it to anyone else.
So it's about retention.
It's about getting to a point
where you're driving a lot of
new users from mobile devices.
And I think, as Ian suggested,
we're kind of heading to that
direction now, where you're
going to be getting more and
more new users from mobile,
particularly younger users,
who just use their phones
for everything.
Never had a desktop, barely
use their laptops.
So yeah, definitely an
interesting area.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Check out
that Moto Guzzi.
That's awesome.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Holy
[INAUDIBLE].
RETO MEIER: There's a lot
of nice things here.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right.
RETO MEIER: Anyway, we could
browse here for hours, but
that's probably not
the most effective
use of anyone's time.
So thank you very much
for joining us.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
for your time.
Cheers, guys.
Thanks.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
All right.
Now the next app that I have
probably got the wrong version
installed of on my sheet of
paper is Realtime T-Bane.
So the developer
of Realtime T--
I'm guessing that's "bon." No,
it could be "bain." You'll
have to tell me how
to pronounce it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's T-Bane.
RETO MEIER: Sounds kind
of like a wrestler.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Daniel,
can you put on the
auto-tuner for this one?
RETO MEIER: The auto-tuner.
COLIN DODD: All right.
You're almost right,
Tayuh-bahma.
RETO MEIER: Tayuh-bahma,
of course.
COLIN DODD: Hey.
My name's Colin.
I'm the creator of
Realtime T-Bane.
RETO MEIER: Thank you
for joining us.
COLIN DODD: Which is an app
that's mostly useful to people
in Oslo, who use the T-Bane,
which is the local metro
subway service.
The app provides a real-time
view of the
T-Bane network in Oslo.
So it allows you to see the
network as it is now--
once you're in Oslo.
RETO MEIER: We're
getting there.
We're getting there.
COLIN DODD: Yeah.
I'm sorry.
You can see in real time,
although maybe
the data didn't load.
RETO MEIER: I'm not sure.
I looked at it yesterday, and
I saw all the little things
moving around.
I looked at it today and have
not been able to see any.
So I'm not entirely sure
what's going on.
COLIN DODD: Oh, maybe it's the
wrong version of the app.
RETO MEIER: Seems likely.
COLIN DODD: No, there is only
one version of the app.
That's the right version.
But it looks like maybe the
data hasn't loaded.
You can try and back out of
the app and load it again.
RETO MEIER: Sure.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, we're
seeing some--
RETO MEIER: You're seeing
the movement?
Cool.
All right.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Data, yeah.
RETO MEIER: I'll back out of
this and see if we can get it
to load up.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Lots of litle
moving circles.
This is so cool.
RETO MEIER: So do you want to
tell us a little bit about it?
COLIN DODD: They have
better internet
connectivity in New York.
RETO MEIER: Probably.
Yeah, this is like a dead
zone in this building.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, so remember,
Reto is standing in
what was once Andy
Rubin's office.
And the entire Android program
was built around him.
So there is all kinds
of wireless devices.
It's almost like keynote
at the Moscone Center.
Nothing works.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, Daniel,
could you switch
to the other box?
COLIN DODD: There is sort of
a bug, maybe, feature.
But it starts at your
GPS location.
RETO MEIER: Yes.
COLIN DODD: Because, while I did
think about maybe fixing
that so if you're outside of
Oslo, it's always set on Oslo,
but I didn't want to make too
many assumptions on the user's
[INAUDIBLE].
So if you want it to force to
load in Oslo, you should
switch off GPS.
RETO MEIER: All right.
No, that's OK.
I enjoy scrolling.
But it's definitely something
you want to consider doing is
you do have the GPS button
effectively on the map anyway.
And nice work on using
the latest
version of the Maps API.
Being able to sort of scroll
and turn and change the
perspective on this stuff
is actually really fun.
Let's see.
I don't know why I can't
get the locations.
That's interesting because we're
getting enough data to
be able to get the route.
So I don't know if you're
pulling the routes down server
side, or if they are
built into the app.
COLIN DODD: The routes are
RETO MEIER: Ah.
So it's likely that we're just
not getting good updates,
which is very strange.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I do think it
might have been nicer to have
a way to search by station,
for instance.
That would allow me to go
directly to what I'm
interested in, no matter
where I am.
But it does also seem like
you're right that purely
real-time data on this system
is unlikely to be useful
outside of Oslo.
ROMAN NURIK: So a couple of
minor things while we wait.
The first is I'd consider
using a
translucent action bar.
Your entire screen is the map.
Go one step further and make
the action bar translucent
above the map.
There are some issues, of
course, with showing the top
left compass and the
My Location button.
But you don't need those,
necessarily.
You may be OK without them.
But yeah, let's--
RETO MEIER: So I'm curious to
know if there was a specific
driver behind the creation
of the app.
Is there a reason that you put
it together, or is it kind of
an experiment of, hey, we have
this real-time data.
Wouldn't it be awesome
to put it on a map?
COLIN DODD: It was
a bit of both.
I'd done a lot of Android
development privately, as
private projects.
And I've never really bothered
to put them out into Play
Store because they were
a bit messy and
weren't very well designed.
So it was really an idea that I
had to force myself to make
an app that I would have to
think about the design and
make it usable.
So it's really sort of just
a play-toy, you could say.
RETO MEIER: It's a pretty
cool toy, as toys go.
ROMAN NURIK: I had one minor
comment about the line
visibility.
Right now, you have the
little eye icon.
Pressing that gives you
a list of lines.
You may want to make those check
boxes or something like
that where you can just
show multiple lines.
If you decide that it's really
not useful to see lines two
and three, you either want to
see one of them or all of
them, and that's fine.
But it is an option you
can [INAUDIBLE].
COLIN DODD: I did
think about it.
I tried to make the main
use case the simplest.
I think most people are going
to look at one line, so I
would rather make that
the main use case.
But I did investigate
that, though.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The one thing
that I'd suggest--
this is just a sort of bell
and whistle thing, but it
would be really cool if each of
these circles had some sort
of extra, perhaps an arrow or
something, so that you knew
which direction it was going.
Now obviously, I can sit here
and watch the circles move,
and I know basically which
direction they're going.
But for instance, if a train
was broken down, I wouldn't
know which track it was on.
ROMAN NURIK: It also relies on
your short-term memory across
a number of different things
on the screen to recognize
what way it's going.
So having an arrow
is a great idea.
I think it would really help
provide an immediate, at a
glance view to what's
going on.
And maybe you add the arrows
only at a certain zoom level.
Like when you zoom in to the
point where you actually
distinguish the different
blobs.
Like when you're zoomed out, you
see all of the blobs all
on top of each other.
And the arrows would even
further clutter things.
But when you're zoomed in, you
may want to add arrows.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
It's a really nice app,
particularly when you're
actually seeing the movement
of the trains.
I'm really not sure why they're
not coming up here.
We do have internet
connectivity, and it does seem
to be loading, but it definitely
doesn't seem
to be coming up.
Such is life.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Then you are
really missing out, Reto.
This is kind of awesome.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I've got it
on my other phone, and it
looks great.
Just not the phone we have
connected to the overlay.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Last
tiny bit is--
well, no, actually
I've got two.
The first, there's a circle up
at the top of the screen that
has an i in it.
That appears to be basically
just a data provider.
I would suggest that that's
probably less important than
the share icon, which is hidden
in the overflow menu.
You might want to switch
those around.
COLIN DODD: I'm not very
good at bugging people
into sharing my app.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, it's
to share the app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, it's
Well then just take it.
COLIN DODD: Yeah.
It's just [INAUDIBLE]
to the Play Store.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I thought you
were going to share like a
route or something.
Actually, yeah, [INAUDIBLE],
that's a good point.
And then also, when I click on
a particular car, it looks
like I should be able
to press this little
pop-up that comes up.
And in fact, sometimes when I
press it, it actually does
change color as if there
was some activity
associated with it.
But there doesn't seem to be.
And actually it's stopped
changing color now.
I'm not sure why.
ROMAN NURIK: But it would be
cool to at that point get into
a detail screen for that
specific vehicle.
And then from there maybe share
its projected route or
something like that.
Something more than just
showing it on screen.
But yeah, I think the utility
of this app is probably
obvious to folks that are using
this transit system.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
That's more a bug report
than anything.
And I'll make a feature
request, too.
I think if I were using this
app, I would also want to
click on the station
and see when the
next train is arriving.
You have that information
if I click on the train.
But if I'm at a particular
station, I might be more
interested in when I'll see the
next train at that point.
COLIN DODD: Yeah.
I was a bit worried about
cluttering the map with too
much information.
So I wasn't really sure of
a clever way to do that.
Because obviously, once the
trains are on the map, which
they're not at the moment, it's
quite a lot of data on
screen at one time.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, but you're
already showing the station.
It's part of the Google Maps.
There's a little
T in a circle.
COLIN DODD: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And in fact, if
I were in the Google Maps
application and clicked on this
T, that's exactly what I
would see is the trains
that were
available at that station.
I don't think I'd see
the real-time data.
That's the value that
you provide.
COLIN DODD: Yeah.
RETO MEIER: The other thing
which might be useful as well
is to provide some kind of
linking to Google Maps so that
once you're looking
at something here.
So again, if you're a local
resident of Oslo, and you know
where the stations are, and you
know how to get there and
everything else, and you are
really just looking to get an
update as to basically how long
you need to wait for your
next train to arrive,
then it's fine.
But it may be worth considering
visitors, people
who are new to the city, who
might want to download the app
and be able to find out how to
get to that particular station
from wherever they are.
So rather than building all of
that into your map, which I
think is fair to say would be
overkill, would be able to
have a way of being able to, as
I say, when you press on a
station, be able to say, get
directions to here, which then
kicks you out into Google
Maps to actually show
you how to get there.
Yeah.
It's a nice app.
It's really well designed,
really clean, really
uncluttered.
I think it's a really
good effort.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Reto, you're the
location and Maps guy.
There isn't a way to install a
layer provider in the Maps
app, is there?
RETO MEIER: No.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That'd be cool,
though, wouldn't it?
RETO MEIER: It would.
And I think we used to
call it My Maps.
ROMAN NURIK: Then you can
open a [INAUDIBLE]
file in Google Earth.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But that's nothing
like this, though.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
Cool.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right.
RETO MEIER: All right, yeah,
thank you very much.
COLIN DODD: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: All right.
So I think that's all
we've got time for.
I'd like to think Hans
for organizing
GDG App Clinic Oslo.
So a round of applause,
everyone, for your organizer.
[APPLAUSE]
RETO MEIER: So thank
you very much.
HANS: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Thans, guys.
[APPLAUSE]